ora Boas pessoal bem-vindos a mais um
vídeo e hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma
estrela ninja muito parecida com aquela
do Naruto é vocês pedem eu faço
e só uma coisa pessoal como vocês já
viram dá para lançar eles muito bem e
também sou muito pontiagudas então vocês
não podem tirar contra ninguém ou seja
muito tem que ser muito responsáveis
para brincar com elas e que estão Duas
Estrelas Uma feita de papelão e a outra
lado feita de papel e o conselho que
vocês é façam de papelão porque ficam
mais pesadas mais consistentes e vão
conseguir lançar mais longe Ok então
bora lá pessoal primeiro vão dobrar ao
meio que vocês tiverem vinga muito bem
para marcar a linha e de seguida
recortem usando uma tesoura
dobre ao meio uma das partes vinquem bem
outra vez e recorte
com uma das partes vão dobrar um
triângulo retângulo ou seja um triângulo
tem um ângulo de 90 graus e de seguida
recortem o chefe deixando o quadrado
perfeito dobre na diagonal
dobre ao meio
para finalizar dobra para o outro lado
ao meio
vou ficar com algo deste gênero vão ter
que cortar dois centímetros nos lugares
assinalados são quatro lugares que vocês
vão ter que cortar 2 cm claro que se
vocês fizerem uma estrela maior estas
medidas não vão ser as mesmas
agora vamos dar de uma rolha uma rolha
de uma garrafa de água normal vão
centralizar rolha no centro ou seja na
interseção das linhas e vão contornar a
volta usando um lápide vocês quiserem
agora ponha alguma coisa por baixo e
retirem o círculo estou a usar aqui um
x-santo parece aqueles operações que eu
comprei muito barato mas pronto até pode
ser com uma faca bem afiar vou precisar
fazer duas partes como estas então para
ficar a abertura nem sítio é só sobrepor
uma parte da outra e pronto fazer o
mesmo processo Ok dobra nesta maneira
bastante simples já tá a tomar forma
aqui a estrela vão cortar um pedaço com
esta aparência Ok então eu senti-nos do
lado e 3,8 do outro
vão dobrar na parte 3,8 para cima da
linha e depois dobrar para cima da linha
dos dois centímetros vão contornar aqui
a rolha cortar o excesso e colar
estou a usar aqui uma cola quente vocês
podem usar outra Cola qualquer ok
um por Cola numa das partes do deste
deste centro exatamente neste cilindro
aí depois na outra e vão sobrepor as
duas partes mas atenção para ficar tudo
bem sobreposto para isso vocês agarram
as pontas e põe uma em cima das outras e
para finalizar vão ter que colar uma
parte a outra seja a parte de cima a
parte de baixo para isso não fazer uma
linha de cada vez Ok não não se aparece
vamos esperar que segue tirem sempre o
chat color para ficar tudo bonitinho no
final e produção Espero que tenham
gostado se vocês gostaram mesmo deixem o
vosso joinha e se inscrevam no canal que
estuda bastante divulgação e avaliação
do meu trabalho e claro Se tiverem mais
sugestões do projectos Como foi o caso
dessa estrela deixem nos comentários que
eu agradeço mesmo porque é a minha fonte
principal de inspiração Ok então é isso
pessoal um grande abraço e até a próxima
tchau